i'm here with friend of the show phoebe
robinson
yeah there
she is oh i'm so excited i love you okay
and we're gonna bring in correspondent
and friend of the show
jonah larson he's giving us some takes
on headlines in the news because this is
in the loop
with jonah larson oh yeah
all right everybody here we are jonah
phoebe phoebe jonah this is how you make
friends in 2020 all right let's get into
the news
hi jonah hi
hi jonah how are you today
i am wonderful how are you you know i'm
having a particularly great day today
i have to say the show's super fun you
know what
i have a new saying tensions are low
spirits are high
oh i know i came up with it in the car
the other day and i was like i want as
many days
as i can have like this and to recognize
them all right jonah let's get into it
we love books you and i it's one of the
things that first bonded us so tell us
about your first story please
my first story is about how books have
been surging
during the pandemic and i think it's
because people
want to physically read a book and use
their own imagination
whereas when you're watching a movie
it's someone else's imagination
that's true yeah you're absolutely right
phoebe what do you think
i mean my boyfriend can attest to this i
probably order
10 books a week and we are running out
of space because we're in an apartment
and he's like i don't know where we're
gonna put these books and i'm like maybe
the bathroom like i have
no idea but i it's just mountains of
books in here
once again phoebe i'm telling you i
think we are
connected because i am mrs crazy books
i love it yes and literally if you want
to meet one of the most articulate and
well-read people
jonah larson okay jonah speaking of
words and meaning and meaningful words
tell us about the next story please
our next story is about the thankful
pumpkin designed by amy lotta
it's where you go and get a pumpkin and
over a series of days write down things
you're thankful for
take a couple pictures and in years to
come look back on it
and just be thankful for all the things
you have in your life and i want
everyone to go get a pumpkin
because you all have something to write
down jonah do the pumpkins last that
long
that was like one of my first thoughts
you take you you you write it down over
a couple days like three
and then take pictures and you have them
for years to come okay
cause also i learned an important tip on
the show which is once you cut into the
pumpkin you've got like
five to seven days so oh my gosh
i think this is great and i think i love
a good sharpie
i love sharpies i collect them i have
them everywhere all over the house and
to just go to town on a pumpkin and
write like positive thoughts i really
like it phoebe what do you think
what would you write i mean i feel like
all my things would just be really
shallow like the first thing that popped
in my head is i would
write that i'm thankful for that men's
health magazine cover with lenny kravitz
shirtless on it which i don't know how
great that is but that is what i'm so
thankful for
you know what though i need that because
i have to lighten up and i live for
comedy so i'll take your pumpkin even
over mine
all right a new seg a new survey asks
two thousand americans
which season straight up makes them
happiest
jonah phoebe drum roll ready
are you ready to find out what season
makes everybody the happiest
jonah take it away the winner is
fall 56 percent of americans say autumn
is what makes them happiest you know
it's really lucky because it's fall
everybody so we're supposed to feel our
happiest
naturally phoebe what makes you happy
i love fall i mean i i love
this serves as a hat i know it's a wig
it's also a hat it's a two in one
i can go out my house i don't even need
a scarf because there's so much heat
retention going on right now
you gotta keep the ears warm i totally
agree
jonah i love you so much and i hope you
are always happy
phoebe i always hope you are happy i
wish everyone here
happiness and anyone who's watching i
know being with the two of you certainly
makes me happy
thank you for doing the news with us
[Music]
today